[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody welcome back
gamespot live it's fresh out max is
joining me what up and we're playing
some apex legends
season 3 is finally finally oh my god I
spent so long downloading this update
but it's all good it's happening things
are happening and look at the brand new
character Krypto he's so cool
very fresh all of the skins are actually
really good skins even both colors so
sick
lots of Dante vibes off of this head
yeah really cool even got like the drone
on the back yeah it looks like a sword
people are speculating that it's
actually a sword it kinda has those
vibes oh yeah yeah it looks really cool
yeah I really like the one with the mass
yeah both the masks ones are pretty good
I like this one especially yeah but
fortunately with white skins in this
game ball maybe in the snow levels it
might not be so bad but you're very
easily exportable that's why people
stopped using the white race skin
because it was easier to it yeah
yeah well with this new math there's all
different types elements and your player
card already looks so dull I wish I had
more like credits to spend with but yeah
all of us the ones I used during the the
limited time event was this because I
had like little anime character strung
all over it is really cute oh man I'm
just looking at the like home screen for
the first time yeah actually it looks
really cool it's got lifeline and crypto
it's one of it it's very cool I like the
color scheme to the green and the black
and the white I dig it can we see the
new battle path I already bought in pass
you get some skins immediately which is
pretty nice this one's actually pretty
cool for bloodhound also hey everyone
thanks for joining us today I see some
returning faces and some new ones we're
all hired for apex that's what really
matters
charms experience loot let's see loot
wallpapers credits gun skin I don't want
to go through the whole pass because
it's a lie
but yeah for the most part you'll just
get a lot of charms wallpapers skins the
usual two another battle pass but you
also get new emo it's like this one's
pretty cool this is very 490 though yeah
definitely maybe they did that on
purpose yeah very cool the skin was
really cool Pathfinder's you suck you
thought you were better than me
now you know the truth and his boys
acting
apparently he's from a different game -
he's also does shoot I got asked a but
he does another voice in another hero
shooter tell Eric to play squads with
you guys well we're actually playing on
xbox today so he doesn't play on xbox is
not an Xbox boy originally so but it's
all good we'll start a game up then yeah
let's do it
so I showed you a couple things if you
want to see more stuff for more
specifics ok he is Korean girl player if
you want to show if want to see more
stuff than just show tell us in the
comments and then we'll hit it up after
we either win or die we'll just keep
going throughout the day we will show
you more stuff yeah for sure
men lifelines stays getting the best
skin yes Jason reminded me of like
Diablo
I love that skin with a pattern it's
really cool yeah all the new skins I
think
Pathfinder's my favorites how many coins
does what you it's 12,000 12,000 red
credits or
have fun don't down regular credits so
they had this bug during
[Music]
there they're still taking the input
that they got from the event that I want
to and they're still probably come out
with another small patch the next like
week or so to cover some these issues
how much time will it updated it took me
like 35 to 40 minutes update is 10
gigabytes I think is smaller this is the
world's edge to create a map so this
right here is and then that's the ice
portion that kind of melts it in between
so it's like a nice green area between
super cool
[Music]
we'll go over to the guys Justin that's
my favorite place the Lutz in this map
is fairly rough it's about the same
amount of loot but it just more space
this guy's not dropping off he's
enjoying the view someone else was going
over there let's go over here this is
this not bigger than Kingston yes it is
I don't have an exact number yet I feel
like it's like 2 to 3 times bigger
it's a lot of running around yet to do
for loop which is kind of rug I mean the
seasons they actually drop you hyper but
the Train the Train is pretty dope it's
gonna be a very very hot zone especially
when the game first starts could before
Gundy wanted to go to the Train yes guys
season 3 it's out now finally it's so
funny it's here like a week ago oh I'm
at that area where you need the special
key to get inside of it huh
yes so I think it's live now I think
they didn't have the key option live
when we were playing but you have to
enjoy a loop tick and then you'll be
able to unlock that door I see a gold
backpack in here is your gold helmet
purple backpack I think there's like
three or four of each like purple so
there's a whole bunch of stuff in there
what's this vault offline still like
lastest I'm not sure there might be like
an update later when it starts open
maybe we said the same thing bring the
to give us the goods
yeah so tell the chat a little bit more
about crypto for those of you who have
not seen the awesome video max put
together yeah there's a couple of parts
of crypto he's more of a forward Reaper
so
throwing right here this thing flies
around in your controller remotely so
you're just standing there and you can
blow doors so you can go up and you can
go down
you can open crates so if yo hey there's
me
yeah there's no more disruptor around no
more disruptor there's no more skull
piercer there's two new pop-ups which
are really cool kind of hard to show you
without enemies around but you can ping
enemies in the beginning people are
gonna pay attention to the drone sound
but after a while people are gonna start
shooting it down there are more yeah not
very strong you say like it doesn't have
a lot of holes I think it literally has
one health one hell yeah but it does
have a small hitbox it's kind of hard to
hit but it's still something I mean
still look fresh yeah it's a little
different than what they originally have
uh yeah yeah I had like dreadlocks I
think that was in the original key yeah
I think picking up the banner with the
drone and really cool yeah I never got a
chance to do that your team was too good
not really I think you're just dying
before I got a chance to but it's really
cool to be able to like pick up banners
from a distance if I have the option I
will try to do that but this is my
favorite area over here so there's
multiple houses surrounding this area
and I like this area specifically
because like in most other areas there's
a lot of loot like spread out it's kind
of hard to hunt down but in this area
just straight through the houses all the
loops right in front of you really easy
to see
it just seems like I was having a lot of
hard times especially when you first
drop sometimes it'll be really rough
you're running around the place do you
think that's because it's a bigger map
so they develop I think they had more
the same amount of food with I don't
know it seems like just more space in
the map with the same amount of Lewis is
just more spread out so it's part of the
fine that's what it feels like at least
I don't know I don't know that's true or
not but it was but it's found a new
cutie
so hopefully we're enemies to it yeah
I'm like I feel like I haven't heard a
gunshot I haven't seen any people yeah
we should head towards this way over
here so we'll go towards the geyser
yeah the geysers work like just a minute
so this shoots you up and then we're
gonna go in this direction
pretty cool I like it because it's
shorter than a regular jump Tower it's
not like it's so long and tall right you
don't really like give yourself away on
accident is really vibrant I feel like
it's a lot more colorful yeah I mean
they have every right to do that because
it's oh there's guys right here blue
shield
[Music]
that was I was really low but I had high
ground thank goodness the ring stops
there I need oh I just picked up a snack
thank you all right all right I don't
know uh I forgot my train of thought cuz
I was a firefighter it got intense for a
second yeah
so we can go towards the train station
over here actually you know what we need
to get away from here yeah so let's head
out this way I haven't gone to this spot
specifically though we should head out
okay
next time we get in a fight I'll use my
throne as for refunds kind of fell into
the fight can't really use this drone at
that point but yeah like before the
fight starts if you know people are
around then it's really good to soar
cannon fire is transferred to this fire
again kind of lit this place but also
the alternator's pretty useless again
because the disruptor is gone so yeah
I'm still using it but yeah if you see
it like a carbine pretty useless fence
what do you think actually about the
things he took out and the things they
added like billy-o is necessary I don't
know he's okay it's not really that good
in my opinion to get back on the grief
it's not that strong that's what it
feels like to me also it's you know
different play style - it just might not
be my lifestyle but he's very very
passive he's basically just takes
himself hard to fight drone so I think
he just brings out the rear line and
other people or the rest of your party
kind of goes forward and he like support
them with the drone yeah and if they
died and he can just grab their banners
with a drone but like once it's Jonas
destroyed you have no passive normal
guard he's just a normal dude walking
around with someone shoot
I see one I'm gonna go there drill now I
hear it actually yeah I'm good to go
okay there's a couple of spots actually
I'm gonna send my uh join explosion off
this mountain
[Music]
my drone nice cool let me write it on
him alright guy Mike oh wait
people get punished harder now if you're
quitting huh
no only in ranked go try to respond are
blow me
all right so for how did I just our team
be a later consequence for tuning in
coming back
my teammate sorry dude
oh there's only two squads left yeah I
think okay I guess he's just gonna roll
with us that's cool I gotta find him
some new loot
yeah let's that cart go bot what is that
yeah so he can shoot it down and get
some loot oh I don't want to shoot it
yeah attract attention blowy trying to
find some stuff for her dude
yeah poor guy that's like always great
when you get respawn but then you have
nothing yeah thank you thank you just
trying to get him something at least I
think that's a bug what interesting I
have a bug on my screen before Oh like
an actual bug yeah oh I had like of
course you know if like my armbands
oh I thought you meant like a flyer or
something like an action slug was on
your stream oh no no no I wanted right
of the I think we should try and get
anything in it I think we got heels
purple sniper stock okay well I get from
shield nice
the thing is just like a Phoenix kick we
should try to get on that you might just
have to run out there and grab it so
like this is the problem with this map
it's so open that it's really hard to
fight hard to find it
[Applause]
[Music]
super low actually
it's fine yeahthere's because we were
they were fighting on the party and
there's still three squads which means
the other squad ran away yeah all good
top three in our first game yes but yeah
the only problem is I felt I feel the
same way now as I did at the event is
there's just a lot of walking and
running around yeah it's it's really
beautiful it's really like this map
needs like sixty teams instead of thirty
yeah even more teams or like more zip
lines and balloons some way to get
around the map faster there's a train
we'll try to hit that up at some point
but yeah oh no we're not gonna get him
don't do this
well drop spicy though yeah
but if you guys have any questions or
want to see something specific type in
the comments we'll try and get to it
yeah playing that season 3 action why
thank you
sinua said Gigi did great
we tried man I'm still like
flabbergasted that that lifeline
survived
she had a purple shield 6 shield all the
way down and then just even like secure
health all the way down she was still
alive she must have had a pixel she
might have some armor swaps to possibly
all right spicy maybe go to the shiny
areas that's a find a train there's a
train well man everybody dropped
immediately okay I'm not seeing a train
but we'll go Wow the train track really
does go that we should go over there
[Music]
I mean I feel like no one drop two
squads went over there we were pretty
far away
really so I never even noticed before
but their zip lines on the bottom here
so you can like jump across the lava
areas it's pretty cool
oh well I thought you just fall in there
and it will damage you obviously but you
won't die immediately
yeah it's similar to like a thermal
grenade you know where that good dose
damage over time also flat line is beast
now with a bull oh yeah yeah it's insane
it's like a better version of the wee
man more accurate very mannish actually
want to try that's the one for the scout
it's you I got my charm
oh my or 99 you can see the charm on it
now noise I got my drone
yeah it's a new addition to a thanks now
all right where are we going
kryptos ultimate is an EMP it is fifty
shield damage and my health damage the
rain just massive and destroys all the
traps yeah it destroys all traps and it
pings enemies in which if you've seen
any competitive play lately you'll know
yeah how important it is the air rid of
those traps
yeah the very last search rooms are like
bunkers where they're just pulled up
somewhere yeah that stuff hurts and so
EMP I consider it a bunker buster'
basically cuz it goes through walls at
wallbangs
so you don't have to worry about
line-of-sight just it's money in their
general direction you start
alright let's got the double tap
they got double tap yeah and I got the
scout I mean personally I freaking hate
the Scout but you gotta give it the sake
of this new hop-up I'm gonna try oh I
have way too much Jam give it a fair
shake and then I also have a hemlock in
case if I am missing you sure yeah very
a not spicy yeah yeah the thing with
kings canyons I felt like there's action
at least like everything I don't know
three to five minutes there's something
you at least you're heard gunshots foot
right there you wanna wear out of here
leader where can you play a peg
everywhere Xbox ps4 PC okay I hear
action I'm just running straight to it
[Applause]
anything yet like there's some better
you spotted all right copy dad still see
no oh oh someone's here ow oh no shuffle
back grapple back I didn't even really
see you anymore show no she'll come care
package is that your dress
oh it's nice yeah we didn't play in news
I because major issues
oh good so I'm wondering why all the
money than because that Marty that we
were shooting was dead but there's a new
mechanic now that you're getting shot by
another team while you're shooting
another team your legend will say oh
there's another [ __ ] there's another
party no freak out so it's a nice audio
cue of like okay
[Music]
I just wanted to be over already
all right let's see if we can get crypto
now okay we were like let's drop spicy
when super far nothing happen well it
was the hot zone and nobody dropped
let's see I think if we don't get crypto
again then we should totally just drop
immediately because I feel like everyone
just drops right when we get a chance to
so I think yeah well I'm half Mexican
Eddie be nice observation I feel like
people are always really curious yeah
all right you're definitely getting
kryptos yay he says he's installing Cod
Mobile no no I heard they were gonna
make it compatible with like a
PlayStation controller or something ways
is that out now yeah oh it is okay yeah
if you can control it with a controller
it's all touching that
I've seen like cook up so that you could
put onto the phone to like kind of turn
your phone yeah I've seen that too but
actually when it's right now see go back
to camp
all right we got this apartments yeah
can you're talking about like these
apartments here the capital city I think
it stays cold land here car let's go
yeah I guess I guess this is the
apartments technically to punish Russia
while can actually go all the way
you can land on public
very funny one else land here there's
definite people here but gathers yeah
the footsteps are so far away
here them it's really hard at all people
drop next to you until they're right
there I feel like again see guys
controlling it
Zach she's like a Rubik's Cube is like
The Ramones see where these gunfights
are I hear it but I don't know which
direction it is they do sound pretty fur
feel like it's like that in this
direction I'm just gonna Park it right
and protip you usually want to leave it
there so you can you can do things to
contribute while your drone is also
doing stuff too because if you just lose
I need that Dave if you just drone by
yourself you feel like playing right
there Oh things that sound oh and
someone's botany I need to armor first
part on the plate
oh yeah I see no there's more people
paint all right how do I get the second
floor has been destroyed
thank you okay so they can shoot down a
drone two stops but I'll just clear yeah
and the HP for the drone is like 110 HP
maybe look every single time I shot it's
like out one shot but the hitbox is
fairly small and when the drone is
destroyed it's about a 40 second
cooldown that's not too bad yeah I am
like scared though where the team go
they didn't brush us or anything no okay
for any hop-up to show you guys double
tap DoubleTap oh my god that goes on the
scout and the Evo right yes you most
amazing with it Scout it yeah it's okay
say it's amazing I heard you
where did that other squad they just
came out and peeked and then that's it
yeah I think people are still wanting to
explore the map right now I'm not going
to did I see terminator are you talking
about
yeah the DLC or the actual movie I did
see the DLC for MK man it was so cool I
also just have like so if you see on the
Wii man right now there is sites and
then there's the ammo clip and there's
nothing else no more skull piercer it's
all gone now I know
breaks my heart but people who are
really fairly powerful I think disruptor
oh these cargo things if you shoot it
when it's lit up a certain color that's
what a little drop yeah oh that's cool
I'm gonna try to get it so because of
like bullet delayed closer eye on earth
you guys notice that gets pathfinder
means will notice but that grapple is
really slow now like the time it takes
to launch out the grapple is very slow I
don't know how to get on top there oh
here you go charge right did you open
already oh there it is
I couldn't find it alright back over
here somewhere I've seen enemy over
there
come on buddy show yourself show
yourself no he's over here
I'm good to go right so they took the
tea shield damage and they're stunned my
joint has been destroyed so right now
with with crypto without
another one and there's Oh
oh we're getting therapy Oh 84 oh man
there's two in there now I got a
guardian angel he's trying to sneak
around the bottom here
like park it right there
so yeah the guardian angel the gold
backpack and the gold Armour switched
abilities now the gold armor now heels
and then the gold backpack
and I felt like I was tearing them up
and then I was out of ammo you know
there's nothing just want to see how
much I feel like I did more damage than
that but yeah again another thing about
this open map is because there's you
kind of just run around willy-nilly and
there's nothing to like focus your
direction in the map like the only thing
that's directing your focus is gunfire
yeah so that's why there's a lot of
third parties in this matter which is
it's very open and then you're kind of
running around and everybody infection
and they're gonna fire everybody
converges there's nothing else to do
everybody converges on that one spot so
you're like constantly getting third
party which just I don't know it's it's
that's the only thing I got to say is
not good about the map design at least
they got to offset that with more loot
just have the matches go faster or them
more players throughout the area more
something to do it's just us no sick
worry about any crazy Thursday
well the new mechanics are just freakin
awesome train is cool the lava areas are
really cool yeah let's try to find the
stream yeah we have a clean screen yeah
I think it's hard to the train yard
first sometimes because the only time
I've seen it just like running around at
the beginning of the mash is where it's
a hot summer it's the mobile hot zone
I feel like maybe the third party sound
cue is like rain anything no the third
party sound cue is only when you get
shot at by another party gotcha
that's when the trailers re let's drop
that grace how about here yeah it'll be
a little spicy
we got this
anything really does look so
again let us know if you guys want to
see something specific
you have stuff from season three two
blue boxes and two pieces of ammo and
[Music]
Miss Santa
this is out yes it is it's indeed today
it actually dropped like an hour ago
I felt like I was waiting forever for
this season three even though
realistically it wasn't even that long
like a couple months we're just spoiled
I really like these cargo BOTS actually
did you get pinged by a drone yet oh is
that yours
no this is mine right oh it's a watch my
college drone
try to shoot it down my drone I'm good
to go really need to find a double shot
I feel like Pathfinder all around is
just slower yeah he's gone too nerve so
if you're a pathway away and again
you're gonna have a tough time well not
a tough time it's just this again even
though I found the next location for us
check your maps
how much
okay
Oh Rainier he's fun thank goodness real
quick even though that guy was camping
like you're just running around all of a
sudden gunfire
so glad we were closer is
running around on this big map
Oh
I've been detected
[Music]
[Applause]
I wasn't too too bad
[Music]
it looks like super quiet and then
everyone was there
yeah I don't know it feels like audio is
really thought that's why I crypto is
actually kind of useful in this map
because being able to see at least Lake
where they are yeah where they are but
it's more than just where they are it's
like where they're running you get the
whole outline that's actually yeah but
the only thing is they have to be 30
meters in front of the drone like it's a
very specific angle and so it's a very
specific cone area in front of that
drone and it makes notice how high does
it go it goes really high super hot
that's probably this the trick right
there like mine or you can only go 30
meters no you can go just mega high but
at that point you're doing literally
nothing yes it Amy yeah cuz if it's up
of 30 meters above the ground you're not
gonna be anything you're plus it makes
noise so that people are gonna look up
and look at it and the shooting and then
it's useless nothing after you gets
right joy so there's no kind of
give-and-take book but I guess because
the drone is easily destroyed
Green yes so large you could just like I
think 200 meters is the range which is
really really far
yeah I mean even right there when we got
hit by the EMP it slowed me down and
like destroyed all the doors yeah
my shields are gone oh there's just
regulars oh yeah I wonder if someone
just broke that in a fight it's possible
yeah doors don't get destroyed oh let's
go there's a train oh yeah we're gonna
run it on that bad boy
we're gonna meet it debris though I
don't think this is enough fight to
reach it
no we're good we got it because it's
coming towards us you know
I mean now that I'm flying it is a lot
further
this is gonna be spicy I could oh yeah
it's gonna be right
boom perfect kind of ah okay I landed on
it yes helmet fell off it
[Music]
Oh purple shield nice so surprise our
guy didn't pick that up
Oh sniper and he fell off with it oh let
me stop the train
Kenny something yeah cool
Peter Momentum's all whacked on here I
know
[Music]
hit the brakes he's like running through
the I'm running a place well that was
fun yeah
ends well except he's like 20 miles away
now oh man he's really far behind
let's just go meet up with ya I feel
like the least amount of times I've ever
played this game where I've landed and
there's never been even back to this
game it's the entire season - we need to
turn off oh he's not yeah I can I got
some famous kids upstairs for
[Music]
yeah I think we need more squats in this
now yeah I think that's gonna be we do
need to find just the hot zone that
general hot zone
feel like there's kind of an unspecified
area right now yeah I mean it also just
came out that people are probably
exploring a lot more oh snap Ritchie in
the chat little sprout a little sprout
yeah that's his new name Oh the stream
renamed him oh hello somebody's here
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
my life is over certain other spots you
guys want to go
I feel like did we land in the ice part
yes I feel like we didn't land there yet
oh go in the ice castle area yeah oh
there isn't that much loot there which
is kind of interesting bit yeah man the
wing man without an extended mag is
brutal yeah so evil floor job be ready
land every job I think the cool thing
though about all the new characters
coming out this new map is like they're
building the lore more and more yeah
and that's really cool even with the
trailers I'm like I could totally
picture myself watching an apex movie I
think yeah when I was when I thought the
event they work they're talking through
the presentation they said like we're
we're gonna try to now collect our
storytelling
I think they're really doing that now
like the right thing to pull all the
trailers and I call the banter between
the
how to say you wearing this games going
now she's really cool ghost type of
story
I really didn't play that much tight in
the wall I don't even play in YouTube
game yeah because the first one didn't
have on campaign didn't see there was
kind of like a sneak peek at the next
legend in the trailer for triptych
like they just saw like there's just
another member like with one of the
squads like we only have 11 squads but
it was like four fully formed
squads or something like that yeah yeah
there's somebody in the dark over in the
corner of the map yes pity oh please
heard that
I have no lovin
why do got these hands although someone
in here is 11 actually running away
the spacing in circles all right that
was the spiciest we've ever drops for
sure we'll just go through the gauntlet
so spicy that there was at least 10
people there with no weapon you're all
just swinging I dropped and he got a
demotion and I got a P 2020 Lou Balki's
can be found in flying drones yeah the
thing is which flying drones and where
all of them you just gotta keep shooting
them down we're gonna find a key yeah I
want to find the key really bad yeah
yeah
yeah I'm geeking out
all right
[Music]
we got through the gauntlet of sweat
ease until I get if any of us would have
gotten 11 that drop I think we could
have taken them yeah my squads gonna
beat up your squad no he's not
I'm the jumpmaster all right do you want
to go back sighs please you want to go
back there do you want there I see oh
you want to go to like that
oh it's right I can this is only the
beginning
good night
if you have a respiratory system kostik
is so funny
he's like so emo and
I feel the most alive when I'm rapidly
approaching death
and again a weapon all right I hear that
oh man there's a lot of people over
there where um he just jumped down but
he's I don't understand where you went
oh he's
yeah something gold I need we're
probably going to die there Wow alright
get to my eyes in the sky I'm good I
don't know why I didn't grab those
[Music]
oh wait oh there's future mama cliff
over here I wouldn't actually get out of
here yeah we do we're getting uh
signaling much room back let's go
they're all here oh god no
I'm just wondering why didn't shoot each
other in the middle and we're getting
screwed they wanted us
oh snap let's see if we can get Jordan
in here yes please
yeah all right full party time
now we're gonna be unstoppable oh I
don't be a hero
what are you talking about man I was
born in a here oh snap I hear you Jordan
you don't hear us I hear you it's like
old gangster dub
he's so funny he's such a troll yeah all
right
speaking about it no I don't think
there's a legend I don't like it
they're also quirky and funny and full
of personality and very like different
personalities yeah what's super
different like gibraltars like physical
design is I think it's like the most
average eyed everybody but his voice is
just so good yeah I love that fake kind
of needed so like culturally diverse
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh and Gibraltar
got a buff - we should test it out I
think you heal faster in its bubble
shield which is how about we go okay
let's land here that's where we jump
very first to see Baba
and well closer to 600 ish
if you have a respiratory system
got anybody on our tail
there are there you
great
whereas the goal that
oh wow they actually all got a gun
were you and your drone just fly towards
them but I had a longbow and in
Mozambique how does the new map feel big
like I feel we'd like we do way more
running than shooting yeah unless we
drop super easy
that's why I was saying that we should
value more movement characters like we
should have more octane to more
pathfinders even rates yet around this
map faster it's just so much war or does
it generally likes maybe speed up
everyone's walking around speed a little
bit fat or even just like get more zip
lines across the map or I don't know
something something to get it across the
map cuz there's just so much poop in
ground and just what are you gonna do
yeah
so if Watson made the Old Kings Canyon
right did she have anything do this no
this is a brand new map she might have
had some hand do that but this is a
brand new planet too
it's not just yeah it's not even same
thing that's so interesting yeah I mean
I'm all about - space stuff
what is the future of battle Royales oh
man good question it's like what can
made their new by at this point was
tomorrow and haven't already been done I
think in Apex gameplay-wise it's just
yeah I would say so to everything that
comes out after 8:00
with a clunky control so the map is not
as good
can crypto ultimate takedown gunsight
interesting I don't know I would assume
so kind of like in cod when you get hit
by EMP and you have a red dot red dot
doesn't show
oh yes I understood
so if you guys didn't know
Wow map came out or was in development
even before apex
really yeah that's crazy making a map is
no joke so you guys saying oh yeah
there's any other kind other new map
next season like they might be in
development yeah it's not easy to build
these maps from a developer standpoint
and I mean if you look at it it's so
detailed yes we are already inside so
much color don't want to use a charged
rifle they got the champion pretty much
let me down every single time I'm
Houston you see you'll be very happy
with that goes all the hits can see it's
like night and day
we're there dropped and it was him or
just if you guys see a anvil receiver I
know you got it
propose ultimate is like an EMP yes
pretty good yeah it's really good it's
like an arc star mixed with like
obviously an EMP but it slows you down
like yeah
it's working laughs you guys nothing
right now I'm going to go ahead slightly
here putting an eye in the sky
yeah we played a few times now and I
still feel like oh there's somebody in
here over there
fill em maybe someone has tried my
drawing
well now you sliding down over there Qin
mo bucket I would make sure that
like I ran over there
[Music]
there's a drone here don't smile can you
guys just
[Music]
[Applause]
so when people start to figure out that
that drone noise is bad and they shoot
it down that's my opinion
yeah they'd do something
so if you guys saw like maybe like a
couple minutes ago that EMP yeah it
again does 50 damage stuns them all and
destroys traps which is a great way to
start the fight because they basically
have if you think about an all-white
shield at that point at maximum there's
if they have purple then at most they
have white shields so that's really good
to start to fight to have to heal or
they have to fight like that if you can
try to run in there get the EMP off and
chasing after them all right and in my
opinion that's definitely hands-down the
best part of Kryptos kid yeah so see the
drawing if you if you leave it alone
then it'll still survey the area for you
going to attack over there
Oh anvil I'll take that yeah oh yeah I
was like we're all running over there
but just [ __ ] consider things just one
guy the ring is closed 60 seconds left I
don't know where's guy is 45 seconds
left we're almost there not can you just
go and hide I think so so I think the
direction of the Ring yeah just get out
of here I want to destroy this dude yeah
he was definitely hiding his waiting
presser right in there yeah really I can
treat that okay
[Music]
okay so we get a chance I'll get to
users amble receiver if you play it
thanks enough
think of this as like the ultimate
wingman it's just like 40 damage a shot
but it shoots faster and it's more
accurate I shot on the gold cargo bag
but I don't know where it rolled their
direction
nice that's when a key I'll take the
salt per vial still keeping an eye back
here seeing where that guy want
oh he's back there I see him I the old
enemy agent over there Qin mo boku GA
yes logged off might roll
which owns you
watch my back does that go I know he's
so slippery
exactly impaired like he has to come out
[Music]
line up I don't have any shields
no I snuck the joke
and I see maybe something good this way
you watch my back I'm gonna go on behind
him yeah whoo 75 on that frog
they're another squad that is you know
how it goes yeah we're okay all of a
sudden oh you know what I should do more
is talk trash
oh yeah the quips yeah three squads left
actually let me do this
you know after watching the competitive
I'm like only around three and there's
already three flies yeah and competitive
you like round five 18 spots yeah
there's people here
very much might die yes I'm reality much
room pasta right here all right
[Music]
I'm looking at the place in front of us
keeping an eye on the area I want to go
to power for coconut distance
[Music]
yeah
so that was every it could be watching
reviving someone anything 10 seconds to
get back on the grid you watch my back
where are these guys I just got the cue
for the third party yeah okay I got
fifty five miles over here there's all
fifty per trailer
oh we're getting sandwich
why is this aria light signaling much
room back
Oh can't be on the way am i doing just
in time
[Music]
[Music]
forty-four
oh she's low I don't want to use my MP
is that when we're really gonna
capitalize on it we're definitely in the
ring though so you know the advantage
here
[Music]
how much time on the link in the ring oh
this is good it's good yeah we're clean
it really good spy I think we can do
this
alright I'm gonna set my EMP off
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm out of gonna sue it's so unfortunate
my hands were very sweaty
yeah I do feel like the
[Music]
that apex champion I didn't see her here
until she was up on the short range I
mean I don't mind that to be honest yeah
noise well ending the stream on a wind
what more can you ask for you guys yeah
sweet well there it is you guys crypto
is in APEC season three years upon us
there's new weapons which we didn't even
get a chance to use laser or the charge
rifle or whatever yeah but yeah there's
a lot of new stuff it's fun it's good
time new map is insane I just got an
achievement unlocked but yeah you guys
thanks so much for tuning in tune in
tomorrow 11:00 a.m. I'm gonna be playing
some destiny 2 with David so make sure
you tune in for that and until next time
we'll see you guys later guys
you